pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche
[Musique]
il fait un froid de canard enfin façon
de parler parce que j'ai l'impression
que les canards eux n'ont jamais froid
ils ne sont pas plus couverts l'hiver
que l'été
et quand la température flirte avec zéro
degré comme aujourd'hui et bien il
continue à patauger dans la mare je me
demande bien comment il faut aller on va
faire un tour dans l'atelier se mettre
au chaud on va passer cette histoire au
peigne fin les canards ont en moyenne
quatorze mille plumes sur le dos j'ai
pas content et je les ai leur permettent
de voler mais c'est aussi un ingénieux
système de climatisation
cette couverture leur permet de
maintenir été comme hiver une
température interne de 40 degrés
pour mémoire chez l'homme elle tourne
autour de 37° regardons maintenant de
coin est fait une pub avec celles ci on
verra mieux une plume est constitué
d'une tige centrale qu'on appelle dans
le rachat du parthe des barbes et des
barbus plus ou moins longues et plus ou
moins souple ses barbes et bar bulles
emprisonne de l'air qui forment une
couche isolante qui protège le palmipède
du froid en hiver
cette capacité à emmagasiner de l'air
est particulièrement efficace avec les
plumes les plus proches de la peau du
canard de toutes petites plumes très
douce et très souple le fameux duvet de
canard
bah il est passé où il s'est envolé mais
non je suis là je suis allé chercher du
duvet j'en ai plein la main et regarder
quand je louvre il prend du volume
il emmagasine de l'air il ya tous
étaient emmagasinées sert d'isolant par
étonnant quand l'utilisent dans les
doudounes et les couettes
tu as oublié de parler des couettes
voilà faut toujours qu'il tire la
couverture à lui oui bien sûr dans les
points est aussi bref quand le
thermomètre dégringole le canard a juste
l'efficacité de sa doudoune l'hiver il
redressait plumes et les maintient
gonflé pour augmenter l'épaisseur de la
couche d'air isolante et se protéger du
froid
al'inverse l'été il peut plaquer son
plumage contre sa peau et diminuer ainsi
la sensation de chaleur
au passage cette couche d'air assure une
bonne flottabilité aux canards un peu
comme une bouée cela dit pour être
efficace le duvet d'oie rester bien sec
et à l'abri des courants d'air pour y
parvenir le canard à d'autres cordes à
son arc
d'autres plumes des plumes de couverture
sur le ventre notamment et celle qui
recouvre les ailes et la queue
je vais vous montrer les plumes
extérieur possède des barbes et des
barres bull qui sont pourvus de petits
crochets qui leur permettent de
s'attacher entre elles pour former une
barrière coupe-vent et ce n'est pas tout
ce grillage est imperméable l'eau ne
pénètre pas dans le plumage
elle est repoussée à sa surface regardez
cette goundo elle reste à la surface de
la plume bien rondes une petite bille
qui glisse
sans s'étaler elle roule sans mouiller
le plumage la plume est hydrophobe
comment est ce possible
eh bien le canard possède une glande au
niveau du croupion qui sécrète une
substance qui ressemble un petit peu à
de l'huile il utilise cette substance
pour enduire son plumage à plumes âge
qui lis aussi régulièrement pour
maintenir l'arrangement des barbes et
des barres bull et entretenir ainsi son
rempart contre le vent et l'eau de cette
manière
même dans la mare il a les fesses au sec
[Musique]
le coup
cyr et coupe-vent doudoune avec son
plumage 3 en 1 le canard peut donc
naviguer par tous les temps enfin
presque tous les oiseaux qui vont sur
l'eau ne peuvent rien contre les marées
noires
le pétrole colle aux plumes ils ne
peuvent plus déployer leurs ailes et
s'envoler à cause du pétrole
la couverture que forme le plumage n'est
plus étanche
l'eau se glisse sous les plumes elle
entre en contact avec la peau les
oiseaux meurent de froid et d'épuisement
ou alors il sonnera car ils sont plus
lourds ils ont du mal à flotter ou bien
ils s'empoisonne avec les hydrocarbures
qu'ils ingèrent en essayant de se
nettoyer reste une énigme
les pattes elles ne sont pas recouverte
de plumes et pourtant elles baignent
dans l'eau à longueur de journée comme
en fait donc le canard
eh bien figurez-vous que le canard ne
redoute pas d'avoir les pieds au frais
la température interne au bout de ses
pattes palmées peut même descendre en
dessous de 10 degrés si ça ne gêne pas
c'est d'une part parce que les muscles
qui actionne ses pattes se trouve plus
haut dans la cuisse bien au chaud sous
le plumage par ailleurs l ehpad du
canard occupe une toute petite surface
des changes avec l'extérieur et ses
doigts sont très peu charnues mais ce
n'est pas tout le canard possède aussi
un système des changes de chaleur à
contre-courant le sang qui vient de son
corps et qui descend vers les pattes est
à 40 degrés celui qui remonte et
beaucoup plus froid que dans la nature
les échanges de chaleur se faisant
toujours du chaud vers le froid le sang
qui descend réchauffe celui qui remonte
et ça c'est tout bénef pour le canard
est quand les sons arrive au bout des
pattes il n'a plus de chaleur à perdre
et le sang qui remonte profite de la
chaleur mais celui qui descend
l'autre avantage en ayant les pâtes
froides c'est que la glace ne font pas
sous ses pattes pour rjh les aussitôt
après et le trouver sur place
qu'est ce que je vais faire de toutes
ces plumes un volant un volant commence
à un volant mélo un volant comme celui
ci pour jouer au badminton
ce sont de vraies plumes comme sur les
volants d'origine au passage sachez que
ce volant peut-être plus rapide qu'une
voiture le record de frappe a atteint
493 kilomètres par heure bon allez je
dois vous laisser pas pour faire mon
canard mais j'ai un match de badminton
avec la petite caméra et si je suis pas
leur jeu me faire voler dans les plumes
aller à très vite
pas étonnant qu'on utilise dans les
doudounes
ça n'a pas bougé l'athlète avec sa
femelle le mâle et la femelle même dans
la mare le canard monsieur même dans la
mare le canard a les fesses aux actes
[Musique]